You've been lied to about rest. While
everyone else treats rest like giving
up, the most dangerous people you know
treat it like loading a weapon. Every
elite athlete, every high-erforming CEO
has one thing in common. They don't just
work differently. They rest differently.
Here's what nobody tells you. Strategic
rest doesn't make you lazy. It makes you
dangerous. When you understand how to
truly rest, you don't just recover
energy, you multiply it. Scientists
discovered something remarkable. 30-cond
breaks boost focus by 13% and cut mental
fatigue in half. Not hour-long breaks.
30-cond breaks. The dangerous restster
mindset shifts everything. Instead of
asking, "How can I work more?" You ask,
"How can I rest so strategically that my
work becomes effortless?" Your
competition is grinding themselves into
exhaustion while you're engineering peak
performance through strategic recovery.
They're playing checkers. You're playing
chess. This isn't about being lazy. This
is about being lethal. When you master
rest, you perform at levels that seem
impossible to everyone else.